we talked about ernest becker
and uh the the
how much value he puts on our mortality
and
our denial of our mortality do you think
about your mortality do you think about
your own death you know what's funny is
i used to not be able to but as you get
older you just know people who die and
there's all these things it just becomes
familiar and and more of a
more ordinary which is what it is but
are you afraid
um sure
although less so
um
and it's not like i didn't have some
kind of
insight or revelation to become less
afraid i think i just
like i say it's kind of familiarity
it's just knowing people who who have
died and
i really believe
in the future i have this optimism that
people or this whole thing of life on
earth this whole thing we're part of i
don't know where to draw that circle but
this thing
is
going somewhere and has some kind of
value and
you can't both believe in the future and
want to live forever you have to make
room for it you know like you have to
that optimism has to also come with its
own like humility you have to make
yourself small to to believe in the
future and so it actually in a funny way
comforts me
wow that's powerful
and optimism
requires you to kind of step down after
time yeah i mean and that said life
seems kind of short but you know
whatever
do you think there i i've tried to find
i can't find the complaint department
you know i really want to i want to
bring this up but the customer service
number never answers and like the email
bounces one way so yeah
you